welcome to this video playing a car bar
in the house yeah this is a frequent
appoint but i haven't played him a lot
recently 9075 it's not very exciting
just check for something else I know
that I usually have them the Scott show
running against him but just some
variety here played played the French so
hmm I could have chicken have seven I
don't know I was very quick here and
delegate sorry and dashing out those
moves mm-hmm so what am i doing him I
think taking taking this pawn looks
risky I'm gambling on that oops instead
i blundered this one haha that's cool
that's a cool cool way to play great
great great great I I simply did not
even see that you can take this this
porn okay but um yeah maybe I can
generate some play on the edge farm um
great
some Luke h4 maybe in the right moment
rook age 40 s is stupid take taking g3s
really nonsense I can I can play this
but what what am i doing next okay let's
just play this if it takes at least the
G file is open which won't be proper
compensation but h5 t h5 cool what a
ridiculous idea
what a ridiculous idea
it took it very quickly I think you just
like he expected them funny
yeah I fatigue that you probably will
check with a pawn and asked me what am I
doing with the F pawn quite them quite
justifiably so hmm yeah
yeah okay if he takes at five okay he
takes it I need some some kind of
miracle you anyway but a stupid stupid
way to play all right just giving age
five away and it's not just a pawn the
whole position goes down the drain my
night is dominated by his bachata
silly game irrilium that happens when I
play the French defense my old bean and
of course it's not the opening it's just
that I have this this history of bad
results with this opening how do I can I
somehow irritate him at least would like
to get that mean may can I get this
night somewhere it's always totally
dominated you five maybe I will take you
five if the night would play it I mean
don't want to be too optimistic here
about anything but if the night would do
something at least it would have been
could be some kind of a game even though
I'm the material down
trying to get the night to beehive
attacking a three at least
taking deform but it can just take you
five that's it's just winning or queen
III it's also wins yep that's totally
enough 94 just um yeah 9424 and I'm done
it's lost it is just lost let's go back
here and can i maybe no I cannot time
morning yeah yeah yeah I know
you know wow what a stupid game black HS
I'm just an idiot idiot do you have to
be to play this more nonsense I simply
didn't see that it hangs I mean it
simply didn't see that and of course flu
and it's gone yeah it also it's just
terrible for the whole structure I
cannot play the Jeep or never after that
or anything it's just just giving the
game away completely just a complete
game this move I play any move f6 or
something is just normal and we replay
nothing happening somewhere between
equal maybe a slide plus for white with
the beef island but it's normal and
after that you're just toast yeah if
he's not making some super silly move
I'm just lost and he played it well so
just a simple one move poem blunder yeah
no need to look at this it's just
nothing happening after age five I'm
just blundering away the pawn in the
game but thanks for watching